Never had the slightest bit of respect for him, never thought
well of her, never thought highly of her when it came to her
business relationship with Destiny. She knew exactly what Destiny
was and she didn't care because well, I want that all that material
gain of >> I mean,
where's the lie? What where's the lie? >> She knows for
sure that Destiny often uses his position, at least allegedly,
as a casting couch. >> She's actually just like a totally
She's a total piece of sh for like no gain,
We're going to get right into this Andrew Wilson thing. Okay,
so Andrew Wilson put out a video, all right? This video is called
Kayla exposed for who she really is. So, if you guys remember
a couple weeks ago, Kayla had a conversation with this Tilly
person, okay? This is the context. You had a conversation with
this Tilly person and this Tilly person basically calls Andrew
Wilson a all right?
We had a a decent amount of drama that kind of spiraled off of
this where people went back and forth over and over again. Um
I believe Progressive Victory offered to pay or or crowd fund
for Tilly's legal >> He's a >> Andrew Wilson threatened
to sue. >> Andrew Wilson's a >> I saw you did Did
you do sit with Andrew Wilson? That's one thing I would disagree
with you doing, which is interesting. Like maybe that's the where
the debate happened.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> I just worry immediately for your safety in that moment
because of the fact that he's a >> Andrew Wilson's a >> I
mean, he's a >> Oh, people get really People got really
annoyed about the cut right there, but I do believe that Ryan
posts a follow-up and just shows that he he cut like dead air
there. There wasn't really anything. >> immediately for
your safety in that moment because of the fact that he's um
I don't know. I feel like I I feel like because you debated with
him, there are people who who enjoy his stuff who are watching
this but they were going to clip this but he's a Andrew Wilson's
a re Just worried >> that's the cut right there, right?
>> admitted on live streams before on his podcast that
he doesn't really believe in in what he understands the modern
version of consent to look like and he his entire career is
built upon a foundational premise that you get clicks by bullying
underage girls or
>> This is
foundationally stupid, by the way. I think somebody really got
mad when I said that. The things she was saying here were just
I don't know why she was saying these things. All right. So,
basically, Andrew was quite upset about how Kayla responded to
this commentary happening on her stream. I do believe that at
some point Kayla does say, like, just so you know, I've never
felt in danger around Andrew or Brian. Right? She does say that.
But, I think that's like too little too late for Andrew and Andrew
is not psyched about this. I believe that is the context.
If there's more context, somebody go ahead. But, that seems to
be what they're going to talk about here and what Andrew's talking
about as this goes on. Well, sorry, Andrew talks about Aaronite's
career here, but it was that this is like the impetus for the
conversation, I believe.
is never going to do
serious or significant pushback against accusations towards me
about anything.
And I don't know why you would expect her to. >> Like,
what specifically? I mean, Wilson was not wrong when he said,
by their definition, he does rape his wife. He doesn't believe
in the idea of marital
Um, he might not believe in it, but he has that he has consent
to do that. It's not rape. That's the problem. So, he might have
represented it that way, but his wife came out and said, "No,
no, no, no, no, I consent to that." And he knows that.
So, maybe he represented it Maybe he couldn't sue. It's still
just weird to to say that about him. I don't know. I think it's
weird.
>> Ever, anytime
Kyla has been presented
with any short of moral dynamic
where the choice is her actual Christian beliefs,
which I'm not sure she even has because she constantly contradicts
them
by saying that they're not found they're they have no foundation
due to Agrippa's trilemma, which is hilarious.
Or materialist >> Dude, Agrippa's trilemma. God damn it.
>> Whenever she has that dialectic in front of her between
a materialist gain or her own ethical purview, she almost always
universally makes the wrong choice. >> Now, that is like
the core critique.
And I do
I sit here and I wonder. I'm like
I actually think that's a solid core critique. Maybe not every
time. But I do think that like if you had to critique Kyla in
one specific way,
that's probably the way. Is like when she has a choice between
uh like personal gain or making the right decision, I feel like
she leans towards the personal gain side with side with rationalizations
basically every time. Now, maybe that's you you could argue maybe
that's like every human. But I do think
I've seen it happen with her a couple of it just keeps happening,
man. >> Basically every single time. I've never seen Kyla
make a good moral decision.
Not even one time. >> Dude, not even one time? Really?
I It's not that like I It's not that I have an example off the
top of my head. It's just like not even once?
Okay, what do you I Maybe you could say it like this. Never made
a morally good decision
where it wasn't aligned with personal
Right? Maybe that's like a more accurate >> a moral decision
not even one time. Not once. It's why I've never had any respect
for her at all.
Never had the slightest bit of respect for her. Never thought
well of her. Never thought highly of her. Never thought she was
anywhere near my
Never thought it.
>> Not So, I believe I believe he's upset that Kayla was
not pushing back here and saying like, "Oh, that's weird."
>> Not even for a second.
I've just never seen her
when there is
a moral decision to be made
I've never seen her make a good one.
When it came to her business relationship with Destiny, she knew
exactly what Destiny was and she didn't care because of well,
I want that all that material gain of Bridges.
I want to I want to be famous and be on Bridges and this guy
is a a way to skyrocket me to fame.
>> I mean
Where is the lie? What Where is the lie?
I will say at that point I also thought that person was a good
person. So, I can't exactly throw the first stone in this, okay?
But I do
I do think that once more evidence came
The weird thing with Kayla was the back and forth between well,
I've ended my business partnership but I'm still friends to like
oh, I'm actually business partners with this person. Do you Do
you remember when she started like bragging about being business
partners with Destiny like three maybe maybe six months after
she said she ended her business partnership with him. It's like,
oh, that's really weird. It's really weird that you go back and
forth on this. I don't know. >> So, I'll look past every
single one of his horrific moral failings that I actually believe
are terrible, like the fact that he married a woman, was in an
open relationship with her. That should be against Kyla's ethics,
but apparently she can see past that. >> Is it? I believe
Kyla talked about being in an open relationship as well. No?
>> Um the fact that she knows for sure that Destiny often
uses his position, at least allegedly,
as a casting couch so that he can utilize his position >> Not
really allegedly. Not really allegedly at all.
Like Andrew
I don't know what does Andrew just mean unless there's a conviction
beyond a reasonable doubt in a criminal court he will not say
things? Cuz like I do believe Andrew's seen all the information.
He says things this way. I think this is way more when he says
like allegedly here, I think this is way more like appealing
to his audience that he's not going to like quote unquote cancel
a man without a criminal conviction. I think that's what's going
on in right-wing spheres is basically like you can't cancel a
guy for any kind of indiscretion unless there's a criminal
And so I I think he's leaning way more into that than saying
like allegedly. It's like not really alleged in any way at all
anymore.
I did think it was funny Don Devil says, she added that that
she was business partners with Destiny in a TikTok argument to
impress zoomers who didn't respect her if I recall correctly.
Yes.
>> And as a famous content creator to leverage women for
which he's done who are often mentally ill. Again, this is alleged.
These are the accusations against him, but it's not like there's
no evidence for it.
When it came to the fact that he
was being accused by Pixie, literally being accused by Pixie
of uh basically handing out her tape
to another woman who he was trying to spark a romantic fling
up with, Kyla was accused by many content creators of going behind
the scenes and trying to hush all of that up.
She was accused by Sunday people and people of doing that. I
don't know if that's necessarily It's like that's like 50/50
accurate, right? There's like a uh
Man, getting back into that, it's really hard to know.
She's just in no position whatsoever
to be the person brokering that stuff,
Like the the issue is when you look at it, Andrew the entire
thing Andrew's talking about, it actually
really does apply to that situation perfectly because she should
have said, "I can't talk about this with you guys because she
had a professional relationship, a business monetary incentive
a monetarily incentivized relationship with Destiny
where keeping his reputation as good as
was like what she needed, right?
So she can't be the person like brokering that back and forth.
She is like sort of
she is um opted out. She's She's conflict conflicted out, right?
Of being the person who does that. Like her she monetarily benefits
by keeping Destiny's reputation as sparkling as sterling as
And so for her to be the person being the the back and forth
the the go-between, it doesn't make sense. It's actually really
bad. Yeah.
But again, it's like she had a decision to make there. Is she
going to make the morally correct decision or is she going to
make the personally
enriching decision?
She makes the personally enriching decision again, right?
It's [__] up.
I don't even know if Andrew will impact this all the way, but
yeah. And And so I don't when I read the DMs, I don't even necessarily
see that Kyla is trying to like hush Pixie
but there are that could be interpreted that way and she should
never have been in that position to begin with.
Here, I'm going to back up a little >> back up with Kyla
was accused by many content creators of going behind the scenes
and trying to hush all of that up. That's what she was literally
accused of doing that. >> Oh, by the way, I'm giving the
like steel man the best
interpretation for Kyla.
I'm not being like mean, I'm not being I'm not like going after
I'm giving This is the best possible situation. Is she sort of
[__] up by being there in the first place? There
is also a legitimate reading that she is trying to shut people
up and and get this handled so that she could get everything
around her back on track, right? Like I don't think people are
unreasonable for thinking that. I I think it's hard to know for
sure, but I do think that like the people who do think that,
I don't necessarily think those people are crazy. >> She
has zero moral integrity.
None. And never has.
That's why when people are like, "Well, why didn't you expect
her to do more?" It's like, why would I ever expect her to do
anything?
Was there a choice here which could lead to material benefit
over doing the right thing? Because I already know what choice
Kyla is always going to make.
All every single time, she'll always make the choice for material
gain
over moral integrity or doing the right
>> So, it's funny cuz I didn't see this,
a lot of people around me saw it and I do I got to give them
credit, right? Like I didn't see this, other people saw and this
is this is he's hitting the nail on the head here, which is yeah,
every single time.
Morally correct action, personally enriching action,
she picks the personally enriching >> Every time. That's
why I just don't understand why it is that people want
so badly
to just be like, why isn't there big call out for Kayla here?
What call out?
>> Are you think you think I'm talking about Quevin right
now, Nora Blaze? I'm >> do you give a person who has spurious
moral intentions
and always chooses
for the left-wing materialism
over the entrenchment of the very faith that they espouse.
Kayla spent an entire debate with me telling me that Christianity
from her view had no foundationalism whatsoever. And when we
got to things which she considered to be materially true, even
though they were metaphysical concepts, she had no answer. None.
She said they're true because I believe
That's it. Completely antithetical to Christianity and Christian
ethics. It was one of the most hilarious things
I've ever seen a person to admit. The chick is a contradiction
machine.
She's always been a contradiction machine. She can never reconcile
the dualism. She holds dualistic ethics in her head. She wants
badly
to be recognized as an academic
and gain the respect of secular ethicists across the board.
But at the same time, she wants to be
by Christians who follow Christian ethics. And it's like these
things come in conflict too much.
The idea that she doesn't believe she believes that her own view
just reduces to dogma.
And since it reduces to dogma, it's
Completely antithetical
to the Christian view. Totally antithetical. I asked her if the
law >> So, it's interesting. I think he's implying that
the Christian view, and I this probably is something that's true,
involves like espousing
Christian beliefs and holding other people to Christian morality.
That that's probably a part of Christianity.
Is that like while you don't judge the people in terms of like
you're not making like judgments of them entirely, You are judging
their actions and saying these don't fall under my these don't
fall under my view. And she totally issues that to say, well,
actually everybody else can act in in terms of their morality.
Right? They don't have to act by my morality. And it's like,
well, one, I don't even know if she acts by Christian morality
in the first place, but two, that like is sort of antithetical
to most Christian views that you could give other people like
leeway to to operate under their moral system.
Right? I just don't think it matters.
Do you believe in the moral system of Christianity is universal?
Yes. Yeah, that's what Andrew's saying here. And she obviously
doesn't do that. She's had multiple arguments about how she doesn't
do that. Also, logic exists
exists. Yes.
Then she says, no, well, it's dependent on my mind. Well, well,
no, it's not dependent just a contradiction machine. And it's
like, no. So, so, you know, forgetting the debate for a sec,
regardless of how you think she did or didn't do there, which
not were not good, but she's never I've never seen her make the
right choice once.
Not saying that behind the scenes maybe she does, I guess, but
the only things that I've heard from behind the scenes that she
does
uh allegedly is try to hush up women who have legitimate gripes
about having their tapes given to other women. She actually won?
No, she didn't win.
She reduced her own ethical system to
Which means that she has no grounds in which to criticize mine.
And then she admitted that. It was likely one of the simplest
debates that I've ever done in my life. I'm absolutely fine with
you reducing my ethical system to preference as long as you're
reducing your own to preference, too. If it's all just stance-dependent,
then you've got no grounds from which to make a criticism. Perhaps
one of the most bizarre I mean, you've got a you've got grounds
to make a criticism, but the criticism is essentially you like
crying out and hitting the other person who doesn't do what you
like. That's what it That's what it is, right?
realistically, I guess man, I'd have to think more. Uh sometimes
I I wonder like there there has to be some holes in in what Andrew
says. I've talked about this before. I just I never watch enough
of his stuff to really go through it. I think Kyla is the person
who like watches the most of his content and tries to argue against
him the most, right? I watched I watched some stream where Kyla
was basically talking about that debate
and just brutally
on her audi- audience and taking call-ins where people were like,
"I think you could have done this better." And she started arguing
like Andrew Wilson. It is way easier to be in Andrew Wilson's
position. I think it it was really funny.
She also kind of admitted she lost the debate and then also said,
"But I got all the good clips." Very interesting. Very interesting
stream.
I don't know I don't know, somebody linked it to me and it I
ended up like listening for quite a while.
I it it just like tells you tells you a lot about a person when
they're like, "Yeah, I may have lost, but I got all the good
clips." I tell It's very weird, man. >> debate tactics
I've come across is why it is that she wanted to get into the
trilemma when she doesn't even understand what it is.
She's talking about why you need to have grounding, which I brought
up in the debate, not that nothing can be grounded. It's just
she didn't even understand it.
>> I I don't think Erudite understood it. The whole point
is saying that like if
She She understood it kind of, but I don't know the way you should
use that is saying like, "Well, we have to agree on certain things,
or else we can't even have a conversation, right?" Cuz if you
literally question everything I say down to like
down down to like, "How can you even be sure that you exist?"
If that's the level of questioning you're going to give me, then
we can't have a conversation. You can question things so much
that a conversation is impossible.
And I think she was trying to hint at that, but then she started
trying to use it in weird she like she like called an audible
and started trying to use it in weird ways. Yeah.
I just mean like they're not really spreading around that much,
at least from what I've seen. Oh, the Kylo clips? I think her
her shorts got like pretty good traction. Hold on. I think her
shorts actually did decently. Am I On shorts. Uh 26k, 20k, 96k,
146k, 677k.
Bro, what the
Am I Dude, I Don't you just re-upload this one again if you get
this thumbnail? I feel like this thumbnail is rough. Like it
doesn't look anything like the rest of her thumbnails or like
how she looks on camera even. Like I'm saying these she looks
like this on camera. I'm not saying this isn't what she looks
like. But like this just doesn't jive with the rest of the stuff
at all.
I understand it's like more without makeup, like a more candid
without makeup shot from a different angle.
But like I don't know why you keep this up on your channel when
you're like trying to present this image. It just It's like something
you should actually
It's like something you should actually take down.
Right? For sure. I don't know why she does that. Anyway, we keep
going.
I don't By the way, I'm not even talking
I'm not talking sh It's like that is not the look she's trying
to present. And I do think the look is pretty important to the
channel overall. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I'm not talking sh right
now even less. I'm literally saying that the look is important
to the channel and that this is not a good look and I don't know
why that It's like got 26k views. You should just get rid of
it. It's like actually It just shouldn't be
Yeah, no, no, no. I don't Trust me, I'm not saying this is what
she looks like on like when she's got makeup on and under good
lighting. That's not what she looks like. That's why I'm saying
she should get rid of it. It's weird.
>> She was reached out to by the Phil Bros. They tried
to >> I'm going to back it up here. >> You need to
have grounding, which I brought up in the debate. Not that nothing
can be grounded. It's just >> You're hedging some I'm hedging.
What do you mean? I'm literally saying this doesn't make sense.
This is very confusing to be here.
>> She didn't even understand it.
She was reached out to by the Phil Bros. They tried to correct
her. >> I wonder if Andrew's got respect for me. I do wonder
kind of.
I cuz I think I think Andrew would be aware of this channel.
And I wonder I if I had to guess Andrew's opinion of me,
I would guess he thinks I'm like a like a simp who flipped on
Destiny and and what was way too early out of the gate, if I
had to guess.
Cuz he did sort of go back and
he did sort of go back and what do you call it? I don't know.
It's hard to say. But I always um I always defended Andrew when
people were like unfair to him. So also, if he's depending on
how tapped in he is, he might know that. I got I I just wonder
cuz I know about influencers who've like mentioned me
and I have like opinions.
Does Andrew know you? I think Andrew would know my channel, right?
He would know like the name. He might have like very top-level
knowledge.
I'm not thinking he like watched a whole bunch of clips or or
videos of mine. I'm just thinking he would know something cuz
when he um when he was talking to Kyla, when he originally said
Kyla's unlikeable in the whatever debate, which we covered a
couple days ago, when he did that, he actually said like I ask
me about anybody in this space, I can give you their entire history.
He basically argued that he watches
right? So I I would just wonder. I would wonder what he would
know about me cuz that's I was like, oh, that's interesting cuz
I watch a lot of stuff. I have a lot of opinions on people I've
never talked to or never really covered even on stream. I was
cur- I was just curious.
she's always wanted it. She's always wanted me to have respect
for her. She's always wanted Rachel to have respect for her,
but
I've never had any.
She's never done anything respectable.
Not that I've seen. Never done a single thing respectable.
Never made a good ethical decision in her entire online career
as far as I've And so when people are like, why is it that you
that she you know, don't you think she should have defended you
more?
That would have been doing the right thing. That would have been
doing the correct thing. The correct thing would have been like,
uh you don't get to come on here and call people that I personally
know aren't this thing this thing. That would have shown some
actual moral integrity and some backbone. No [__]
way. You're asking for way too much from an immoral troglodyte
who has
>> I wonder where Andrew would have drawn the line there
on her response. Cuz I do think it's probably unreasonable for
Kayla to like say, I'm kicking you off cuz you called this guy
a or whatever.
Like I wonder what he was expecting. Like where's the line for
him?
He He expects this like, oh you're going to defend me by by kicking
this person off and saying, I'm not going to let you do that.
But if she just argued like more aggressively for him and Brian,
would that have made a difference? I did think it was like kind
of weak. She just did the like, well, you know, I like Brian
and and Andrew and I've never felt danger any danger around them.
Right? Yeah, I wonder where the line is. >> No ethical
foundations reduces them all to gibberish so that the secular
leftist will like her better.
She needs them to like her better. Someone has spent many years
believing I was morally superior while actually being extremely
selfish, materialistic, and hedonistic. I can see right through
Kayla's facade. Glad I found God in 1 SP. Yep. Yeah, she got
well, I I refuted her entire argument 5 seconds. I asked her
if we were getting into it about Agrippa's trilemma.
And I refuted it like 15 seconds.
That no position has any foundation. And I said, "Does that position
have any foundation?" No. It's So, is that position true? Said,
"No." And I said, "Okay, well, then that's the end of that."
And she said, "Well, why are you running?" I'm like, "What are
you talking?" It was just refuted. Self-refuting, you idiot.
Brian even brought up the definition. It doesn't
You can define things, right? You can do whatever. I don't even
care about that. >> The Agrippa's trilemma thing is just
too hard for people to understand.
But I do think those that clip, that like section of that debate,
that was kind of another whistleblower moment,
That it shows like you could you could wield something, but it
shows a a like a lack of uh man, a like a lack of second-order
thinking, which I've never even accused Kyla of before. I do
think Kyla is like capable of second-order thinking. It was really
Like I think it was it was two things clashing. It was
I think she had normally integrated information, like updated
positions, but she doesn't want to admit she's wrong. So, she
like has to keep doubling down in weird ways.
I don't know. It was it was really bad,
No, the whistleblower thing is worse because it's obviously worse
to everybody cuz it's it's like obvious on its face that it's
wrong, right?
But I'm saying it was another moment like that where she was
obviously wrong. She was obviously like refuted
And she couldn't understand why, or she just kept trying to force
the same thing
And I'm not I'm not sure which.
But if
Uh yeah, I'm not sure. I I actually don't know. But it is like
equally being equally wrong to the thing before. Like like she
was just as wrong and just as aggressive about arguing she wasn't
But it's just a lot harder to to see clearly, to see like as
a like open-and-shut case.
I wouldn't I wouldn't even give a
If the chick just drubbed me in a debate, or vice versa, it has
nothing to do with anything, ultimately. People are going to
lose debates, they're going to win debates.
It's irrelevant.
Totally irrelevant.
What is relevant is at any single time there has been a moral
choice for this chick to make, she makes the wrong one every
single time without fail. Somebody tell me a good choice that
this chick has ever made in her online career.
When there was any kind
of moral decision to be made.
Which was not self-serving,
but actually could have hurt her. Oh, there's a choice and I'm
going to do the thing that's not completely self-serving and
may even hurt me with my fans and base and things like that.
Name one. It's never happened.
Wasn't she mad at you when she left? She was very
>> I actually think this is again, like the best the best
criticism you could have of Erudite is that she will not make
that decision ever. She's never once made that decision in her
entire life. Well, sorry. In her entire online career.
I'm trying to think of the time she could have done that where
she could have like made the correct decision
like done the thing that didn't benefit her. And I can't I literally
can't. I can't think of it. >> No, she did shake my hand,
but she did it like this. She wouldn't look at me and put her
hand behind her to shake my hand. Yeah, whatever. She was pissed
off because apparently it's bad faith of me to not let her be
bad faith and derail when when she decides she's going to derail
a conversation on Christian nationalism
into foundationalism
and then refute her own foundations for it and that I wasn't
going to just like let her get get away with that. Apparently
that's bad faith. Apparently I'm supposed to solve Agrippa's
trilemma, this thing which is self-refuting even though I solved
it in 15 seconds when she asked me about it, but whatever. So,
that's the thing, right? It's like anytime anytime I've ever
seen
there be a materialist choice
or a
a non-materialist choice which would have some integrity involved
in it inside of any dilemma that Kyla has ever done. Are you
going to debate her again after this? I would have debated with
her the next day.
I don't give a
Her view to me is a nonsense view which is easy to refute
and it's just followed by spurging. Great entertainment for me
to go on and wreck Kyla. I've been doing it for years.
Years I've been wrecking this chick.
But it has no bearing at all on what we're discussing right now.
Who cares about debate this or debate that? What I'm saying directly
is that I've just never seen her make a good moral choice once
in her the entire history of her online career.
And so I have zero expectations. I've seen it >> He uh
he does keep running for Pisko. Yeah, I don't know why he does
that.
I assume it's because Pisko's capable of being as pedantic and
annoying as he is and he doesn't want to deal with that. He knows
it's going to be bad content and he's not like guaranteed to
win.
It's like that an argument between Andrew Wilson and Pisko could
easily just bog down in some totally semantic
for like
pedantic and like arguing semantics for like hours and go nowhere
and he might not even win, right? It It It could be like horrible
content and the possibility of losing. It's like the worst of
all worlds, right? For Andrew Wilson. I think that's why he avoids
Pisko because realistically
I don't think they argue in the same way. I think Pisko does
like substance. They're similarly they'll similarly drill down
if they're if they're like pushed on a point and they feel like
they're wrong, they will dig into
semantic arguments instead of actually continuing on in a very
similar way.
I won't say they're the same.
And I think Pisko is more accepting of like like he'll take on
all comers versus Andrew, but
You debated Pisco on Jan 6, right? Um did I debate him on Jan
6? No, I don't think so. I don't think I ever did. I've I've
talked to Pisco about a couple different
But unfortunately, whenever I talk with
I end up basically having to defer to like his legal opinion.
And so I just I I came up with like a rule for myself where I
didn't want to actually argue with Pisco if it was about the
law. Because realistically, I have to defer to him. And I remember
it happened in a conversation about
Oh, what was it? I think it happened a conversation about whether
or not Trump would be on the ballot.
Where I had to defer to him on the law. And it was very frustrating
to me because I was like, I'm pretty confident I'm still correct,
but like if you say this is the way the law works, then that's
fine. Then I I agree with you. Then I guess I would be wrong.
And then basically, he was arguing that Trump would be taken
off the ballot. And then it was a what? Nine 9-0 decision in
the Supreme Court in favor of not taking him off the And I'm
like, dude.
So, yeah, it's it's difficult, man. Andrew B show charitable
to these women streamers and they just turn on him. Kyla, Grace,
Sarah, the list goes on and
That's why my me not following my own
of working with female All these god damn women keep stabbing
Andrew Wilson in the back. What the That's why my me not following
my own rule of working with female content creators was a huge
mistake.
And one I'll never repeat. Ever. These people only engage in
scripture to use it against Christians for being mean and defend
their sin. True. She didn't take the unlikable comment too well.
Well, that was look, I always know when Kyla decides that she's
going to move into bad faith mode.
Right? I always know exactly how you can beat her every single
time. >> That face mode. >> You just attack her ego.
That's it. The woman's ego is the size of the Death
And you don't even really have to attack it much. You just poke
and prod a little bit and she'll do the rest. She can't help
herself. She didn't take the unlikable comment too well. Do you
think that's why she didn't defend you with Tilly? Nope.
That's not
And I say this without trying to disrespect Andrew.
I do think Erudite and Andrew are very, very similar people like
at their core.
I think they're very similar people without the the part where
Andrew Andrew will make the sacrifices, okay?
But in terms of how they operate outside of being willing to
sacrifice to stick to your principles, I do think they're very
similar people.
And I think Andrew, when he says this, like I know to just attack
her ego and she'll get I think Andrew's very similar.
And he he knows what affects him. And so he's very good at affecting
somebody who's similar to him. >> Why? If Kyla ever showed
an ounce of moral integrity about any >> Although I will
be real, that's like basically all streamers.
Right? You're going to essentially hit that same thing with all
streamers. People are streaming because they have
They want that ego like soothed and
Like it's not really
particularly complex analysis to be >> That's not why.
If Kyla ever showed an ounce of moral integrity about any issue
I'd be one of her most adamant
Whether she was a leftist or not. I'd at least be able to be
like, you know what though? Kyla usually does the right thing.
I could at least say that.
I could at least say, you know, for all of her failings and her
stupid worldview and like that,
the one thing you can always give Kyla is that she does the right
thing.
But I can't say that.
Fact's the opposite. The one thing you could say about Kayla
is she almost always universally does the [__] wrong
thing.
It's like so when at what point am I going to have expectations
that these people ever do
take any moral action
instead of just pure self-serving materialism? Just basically
never. I'm just never going to have that expectation because
they they never are going to.
I I never have to be disappointed.
I never have to be disappointed ever at the decisions that they
make because I already know that they're if it's a choice between
materialistic gain or doing the right thing based on your integrity,
your actual moral foundations, I always know which decision they're
going to make.
I understand. I've seen her on videos for years and never had
a good take in the Christian world view, never once. Drove me
insane that her argument for why Christians can't hold power
is that Jesus didn't accept a kingdom provided by literal Satan.
Then she didn't even understand what the passage was about. I
had to point it out to her. She didn't understand the reconciliation
in Acts. Doesn't know anything. I don't even care about that.
Be a [__] or be somebody I think is stupid. I don't
even care.
I can deal with that.
But for the love of all that is good, can you just make a [__]
right choice every once in a while? Like you would think that
you would just make it by accident at this point. >> Dude,
yeah, I I understand a lot of people don't like Andrew. And I
mean
on a personal level, I don't really like Andrew. He's just a
caustic [__] There's not really much to like there.
He is like an [__] the time. But on this one point,
like I think it's actually correct. I wasn't going to do this
video. I was like, "Ah, it's whatever. He's talking about Aeryn
Nye. Who cares?" But then I started listening. I'm like, "Dude,
the core criticism is actually like what I think is the core
criticism by most people who are critical of Aeryn is that she
will just always prioritize herself, her professional gain over
everything else. Always, right? It's just it's pretty clear.
And it was interesting to hear Andrew Wilson feels like the exact
same way because I don't think Andrew Wilson talks about like
his moral judgment of a lot of other people as often unless he's
like talking about, you know, OnlyFans girls in a debate or something.
He's not really judging people. I don't hear that a lot, right?
Like realistically
and that's not totally unexpected cuz he will he'll debate people
regardless of how he feels about them. Yeah.
>> And how do you make so many wrong moral decisions? You
would think that you just accidentally made the right choice
at some point. Oops, I accidentally made the right decision.
That's how many bad choices this chick has made. Nope, sure is
If there's a wrong choice to be made, she's your girl. I've watched
her in the space for like 4 years. I think closer to five than
four even. Does she even have substantial material offered to
her where someone could at least justify it to some extent?
Nope. Yeah, that a show she was doing
>> Wait, substantial material offered to her so that somebody
could describe it or so somebody could justify it. Is that Is
that question I didn't realize what that question was. Is that
question asking like does she at least like make money? Does
she at least make enough money that she could justify being like
a totally immoral wretch?
Andrew's response is uh nope. No, she doesn't even She doesn't
even really make money. She doesn't even really get that much
out of it. She's actually just like a totally She's a total piece
of [__] for like no gain actually.
I think that's what the question was, right? Enough material
like as in for material gain, they're talking about money or
whatever else, right? Dude, that's crazy. >> Does she even
have substantial material offered to her where someone could
at least justify it to some extent?
Nope. Yeah, that a show she was doing with Destiny called Bridges
which was the most boring you ever saw in your life.
The entire attempt was Destiny attempting to be the new Joe Rogan
yet with a female host for reasons nobody >> The new Joe
Rogan who just basically has contempt for and doesn't understand
the average human being.
The new Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan famous for being a guy you'd want to sit down and have
a beer with even if you were like a construction
Sure, Destiny's going to be that guy, the guy who like hates
the average person, who has total contempt for the average person.
Surely that was going to work, guys.
>> But that was what he was trying to do. I'm going to
get on uh you know, leftist and people like this and >> Bridges
had potential even if Destiny did even an ounce of prep work.
Maybe
it's basically saying that like if Destiny was a totally different
person it's it's like pondering a hypothetical that can't exist.
If Destiny was a totally different person then possibly it had
it had like some
Honestly, if Kyla was just a producer, it probably had more potential.
Right? If she was just preparing and and providing like briefs
to Destiny on who these people are and and just drilling him
like on stuff and making sure he was he was prepped for the interviews,
that would probably be better. It it does suck cuz I remember
telling Kyla like, "Hey, just keep going with it. Like you will
make it work eventually."
But she had this other thing. Maybe this would be a moral choice,
but I don't know if this is a moral choice. I don't even know
how to justify this. I think she could have monetized things
like as aggressively as Dan did.
Dan came in so if you remember the history of Bridges, they were
setting up that set, the set was disastrous, okay? And then Dan
came in for a camera test
on some some set they were setting up and and this the podcast
just flowed way better, right? With Dan and Destiny. That's unfair
to Kyla a little bit cuz Dan and Destiny have been streaming
together for well, five, six, seven years or something at that
point, right? It's a little unfair to Kyla.
but it just flowed better. It was like automatically better.
And then Dan was like, "Oh, well, I guess I'll just do anything
else and I'll also monetize this entire community. Uh 676767.
And Dan just monetized the entire community, made a bunch of
money, and Kyla didn't do that. And I think that was like to
her a moral decision to not like lean on Destiny's community
and get them to sub and like solicit them as much. And Dan had
no such compunction, okay? He just solicited everything. Yeah.
so Kyla maybe could have made like more money and gotten more
I don't know.
But realistically
they just they don't have chemistry either, Kyla and Destiny.
They've got like zero chemistry. That's they just they got like
zero chemistry together. It's kind of weird. I don't know.
Kyla wanted a separate community. Well, you wanted a separate
community. Destiny operates with like a cult. I never was going
to work if that's if that was the goal they were going for. It's
very different. I think she wanted Destiny to be a serious person
in a way that he never could be, right?
Like he was never going to do that. He never He never wants to
be a serious person, ever.
So it's like you're you're going for something that can't exist.
Which hey, he fooled me at one point, too. I don't know how long
he fooled me for. It was definitely not as long as he fooled
me on him being like a decent person. But uh he fooled me on
thinking he was going to be a serious person for a while. Zentreya
exposing her over? We covered it at the beginning of the segment.
Go back and watch. >> Yeah, I'm going to get on uh you
know, leftists and people like this, and we're going to do the
Rogan thing where I just ask some questions and we we kind of
talk in depth about your view and this and the problem is he
ain't no Rogan.
They never understood the pulse of people and what drives them.
They never understood that you have to appeal to people who are
in the mainstream, and those are average individuals. These are
not people who have tons and tons of time to research every issue.
These are not people who have the luxury
of being able to spend but maybe an hour or two uh or sometimes
only three three four per week
on politics and what's going on in the world. And so for most
people, the construction of conversation is a better
to move ideas in and out. They wanted to do this, but they don't
have the necessary charisma.
>> Wait. Dude, it's actually so funny. He's pointing out
like some legitimate problems with Bridges. I don't think that's
all it was. It was definitely in a network with like other big
creators, right?
And it sort of succeeded in that way. Kyle has succeeded in helping
build Destiny's brand. Unfortunately, that all falls apart when
Destiny gets exposed for what he was doing, right?
Um Jam, I see you're saying you you'd like really liked anything
else. Uh I liked anything else at some point. I definitely did.
It Anything else falls apart when you realize what it's like
all in service of, right? Like unfortunately, it stops being
as funny to me. Um I start to see the people like in a very different
way, and it stops being funny like in the same way. I don't think
humor really exists in a vacuum.
If you If you think somebody's like morally reprehensible, it's
very difficult to find them funny.
Um you can, but it's very difficult to find them funny overall,
right?
So, I I agree that the podcast was good for a while.
Unfortunately, what they probably should have done is they should
have just leaned into the like Destiny's left wing Ethan Ralph
from the very beginning, right? And I think that would have all
worked better. But the problem is Destiny's got too much of an
ego to admit that he was Ethan Ralph.
If If they'd leaned into it, could have been really good content,
just a total like slop show, slop fest the whole
But when Basically, when people would point out that Destiny's
like a totally
immoral, like zero impulse control
he would freak out, right? I think Richard Lewis did that once.
Richard Lewis was sitting there and being like, "Why are you
pulling up like a bunch of on your tablet right now?" Right?
He had like his Google Drive opened. Like stuff like that was
funny.
more or less funny now.
They probably They probably should have been like leaning into
stuff like that to be maximally profitable, maximally
Anyway, it was never going to work. Basically, Kyle bet on this
person being serious, and it was just never going to work that
way. It just doesn't work at all. It was good except when Dan
used it as the evening stream for militaristic
Um I mean, I liked it back then when I was like on that page,
right? I mean, I To be fair, I also did start pushing back on
like the idea that Hassan was anti-Semitic or like his people
were all like super anti-Semitic.
I thought they had like some anti-Semitic moments, but
Once it was like, "Oh, we should try to get them all banned off
the platform entirely." I was like, "Okay." Or we should get
the platform like fall like to fall apart. It's like, "Dude,
this is This is too much. This is way too much." I even thought
there were some problems there, right? But it just it went way
too far, way too fast. The election coverage got me so Dude,
the election coverage [__] sucked. I tried to watch
their election coverage. It sucked so badly I that I was like
sitting there like, "I'm going to go live. I'm going to go live
and actually cover the election cuz this [__] sucks."
Anyway, being funny is not a thing So, being funny is a a thing
that exists outside of morality.
But your perception of a person morally affects how funny you
find them. That's what I said. That's what I mean. I think you
would agree with that. So, you could try to differentiate, but
I never said that you can't find a morally reprehensible person
funny. It's that if you could see how morally reprehensible they
are, it's difficult to find them
Which is just true. It's why there's a whole bunch of lefties
who can't understand why why um Trump is funny. They don't understand
why Fuentes is funny, right? Is Fuentes an outlier in terms of
his morality in relation to how funny you find him? Well, the
thing about Nick is I I don't know if Nick like um hurting people
in the same way.
You know what I mean? Probably there's something there along
with like the like doxing that Groypers do that you could go,
but realistically Nick like basically is just like a racist online
that doesn't never had a lot of outreach. Love to see now that
he has political power, how is he actually using it, right? Yeah.
Anyway,
uh I'll back it up by like 10-15 seconds so we could keep going
with this, but we're basically done with this. >> rich
individuals. These are not people who have tons and tons of time
to research every issue. These are not people who have the luxury
>> Casually admitting you don't find Nick morally reprehensible.
I don't think I find Nick. It's like Dude, if you If you think
I'm like putting um Oh, wait. Nick Fuentes. I thought you're
talking about Nick Diore because there's a picture of Diore right
Um Yeah, I'm not putting Diore on the wall. You know what I'm
saying? >> free of being able to spend but maybe an hour
or two uh or sometimes only three or four per week
on politics and what's going on in the world. And so for most
people, the construction of conversation is a better
to move ideas in and out. They wanted to do this but they don't
have the necessary charisma. Why do you think Destiny hates Rogan
so much and is always seething about him? They tried to be left-wing
Joe Rogan.
And he couldn't do it cuz he can't appeal to that audience. There
is no appeal. What is the appeal? >> Anyway, huh wait,
hold on. Have you not seen the 1,100th
joke that he's like joking that he's a How does that not appeal
to the average
He talked about like a fool, okay? Like a hundred different times.
Wait, is that not appealing to the average person? Answer, come
on. Is that not appeal That's got to be appealing to the average
person, right? No? >> That's my take on Kyla. Why I like
her or don't like it. >> Oh, what's about Kyla and Tilly?
Okay, perfect. There you go. There's the
There's the video. There's the video.
All right. Cool. I just wanted to cover that cuz that video is
I thought it was good. That's actually substantive critique of
Very interesting.